I'm John Perry and I started the group
called stated clearly what we do at
stated clearly is we take complex
scientific topics like genetics and
evolution things like what is DNA and
how does it work what is the evidence
for evolution and can science explain
the origin of life and we take these
concepts and we simplify them and we put
them into short animations things that
can be shown in the classroom or you can
just watch on YouTube if you'd like and
all of these videos are free to watch on
our website at stated clearly com and
we've got flyers in the back as you're
exiting there's a table outside the door
where you can grab a flyer some stickers
or some other little things out there so
make sure to grab that if you're
interested but today I'm gonna be
talking about my favorite subject of all
time the thing that really got me
interested in science in the first place
and that is evidence for evolution in
your own backyard
this is a picture of me I'm the I'm the
kid in the middle kind of looking at the
camera got my twin brother there and my
little brother there and our dog Chester
and Chester is probably the main reason
that I love science he was my first
interaction with a nonhuman creature on
a regular basis and I was just from day
one fascinated with this guy I wanted to
learn how he understood the world how he
was different than me how he was the
same as me and one of my earliest
memories is laying in the yard with him
petting him and realizing for the first
time that how similar he was I was
paying attention to the bones that were
in his body as I was petting him I
realized that he had he had a ribcage
just like I did
he had his front legs had shoulder
blades like like I have and his back
legs were attached to hips just like
mine and that was just an amazing little
realization that I had that he was built
just like I am and if you look at a dog
they they've got a kneecap and a normal
knee just like we have and they have
what I thought was a back word to me
this funny-looking thing
the end of their leg facing backwards
and I started feeling that and and
exploring it and I realized that's
actually his heel bone there's he's got
a tendon just like I have in my heel
this means that dogs walk around on
their tiptoes and I was so excited about
this that I told everybody I knew it was
the thing I kept talking about at dinner
and the reason I was so excited about
this is that I realized this was this
was a turning point for me as a little
kid I realized that I can learn stuff
from my parents I can learn stuff from
books but I can also learn stuff by just
exploring by just looking at the world
and being curious and using my brain and
that that sparked a whole new world of
exploration for me a few years later I
was watching a nature documentary by
David Attenborough and I really liked
this guy because when he would look at
animals when he would explore he had the
same kind of joy that I had when I was
doing this exploration so I really kind
of he was kind of my hero and he in this
nature documentary he he taught me about
evolution for the very first time I'd
never heard about about four and the
theory of evolution is very simple but
it makes some extremely bold claims
about living things first of all all
life on Earth is related we all share a
common ancestor the second bold claim of
evolution is that life evolved through
natural processes things that we can
understand we can actually study these
and understand them and that that was
really exciting for me I can actually
learn why my dog is similar to me and
why he's different from me by studying
by looking at how the world works
evolutionist is powered by a couple of
different processes one of the most
important is descent with modification
and this simply means that when parents
have offspring those offspring are
slightly different than each other and
slightly different than their parents so
here I've shown that in this little
cartoon that these children have
different colors that they are born with
the other another very important aspect
of evolution process of evolution is
natural selection and this simply means
that in any of an environment some
creatures will be more fit for survival
within their particular environment some
will be less fit so here we see our
chameleon coming in and selecting
everybody who does not look like a leaf
if you allow descent with modification
acted upon by
natural selection to occur over multiple
generations eventually you get
adaptation a group of animals will or
plants will become more and more fit for
survival and reproduction within their
particular environments and and that was
it that's what I learned it was
absolutely fascinating to me anybody
guess what these are
chickens someone said chicken these are
chicken feet and I've got a question who
here thinks that chickens can swim is it
now I don't mean they can just keep
their head over water what if you throw
them in a pool but actually swim with
purpose just a handful people who thinks
they cannot swim with purpose all right
well let's take a look at the evidence
does rocks you the chicken as seen on
YouTube chickens can actually swim very
well as you can see sometimes they do it
on on their own she was placed in a
swimming pool but when thinking about
evolution if you look at a chicken's
feet you can see that there's a little
bit of webbing between their toes and if
you look at your own hands there's a
little bit of webbing between your own
fingers not very much for most people
some people have more some people have
less and the same is true with chickens
some have more webbing some have less
and you can easily see you can easily
imagine that if there was an environment
that was selecting for swimming chickens
maybe the only good food was in the
water for example over time those with
more webbing between their toes would be
selected for by nature until you you
would eventually get something similar
to this this is a duck's feet yeah and
this type of evolution made a lot of
sense to me when I was first learning
about it this is just a straight line
and evolution you go from a little bit
of webbing to a lot of webbing it's a
very simple thing to understand an
evolution but shortly after learning
about how evolution works I got stung by
a bee and I looked into how stingers
work because I was curious
after getting stung
and I learned that there they are
extremely complex structures so here's a
stinger a little bit close closer up and
if we zoom in even further we can see
how complex the structure is there's
these backwards facing Barb's you have
these two Barb's and as they're pushing
as one pushes in and then pulls back
that pulls the entire stinger deeper
into your arm or wherever it was that
you were stung and each time that thing
pumps it enters further and further into
your skin pumping venom as it goes this
is an extremely complex structure and
when I learned about how this works I
was baffled thinking how on earth could
something like this evolve it seems way
too complex
there's too many moving parts and if we
want to understand how complex
structures like stingers evolve we need
to understand exaptation so it's kind of
a new vocabulary word for us but an
exaptation is when a trait or oregon is
found to be useful for a new function
one for which it did not originally
evolve this is an exaptation he's this
parrot has a back scratching device
which it evolved but that back
stretching device did not originally
evolved to be a back scratcher of course
it's his feather for flight now this is
a silly example of exaptation because
it's kind of hard to imagine how this
could possibly give the parrot a
survival advantage so that means
evolution probably won't continue
shaping feathers for the purpose of
scratching backs but oftentimes
exaptation x' are extremely useful for
survival and reproduction most most
plants have veins and their leaves and
the purpose of these veins is to to
carry sugars and fluids from the leaf to
the plant and vice versa and so these
veins have been evolving over time to do
that more and more efficiently if we
look at holly leaves their veins
continue to do that purpose but the
second purpose has developed they have
spikes on the tips of these leaves and
and these spikes have developed simply
because there was a mutation that
occurred that caused the veins to extend
past the margin of the leaf and when
they extend past the margin they
and they become prickles and animals
that like to eat plants don't like
prickly leaves and so this gave this
plant a survival advantage and so this
is an example of the next app tation
that caused a zig zag to occur an
evolution evolution was pulling leaves
to be more and more efficient at fluid
exchange then there was this mutation
that occurred sometime in the past
causing those veins to become a weapon
and now we have Holly leaves which are
highly advanced had these highly
advanced weapons on them here's another
example of a leaf of a plant who's
evolved the same strategy independently
this is one I found in my own backyard
and these spikes are extremely extremely
successful at getting me not to pull
weeds in my yard so it works so that's
what an exaptation is when a trait or
Oregon is found to be useful for a new
function one for which it did not
originally evolve acceptation everybody
to say that acceptation acceptation so
an elephant's trunk is an example of an
exaptation it's a modified nose
sea lion flippers or modified hands
sloths hooks those hooks they use for
climbing are modified fingernails the
wings of birds are modified arms and
this might seem strange because they
seem so foreign they seemed so unarmed
like like these just completely unique
structures but when we look at a chicken
developing the egg we see that chickens
start out with this 3 clawed hand and
that 3 clawed hand eventually fuses
together into the chicken wing that many
of us have become familiar with during
football season bat wings same thing
they're modified arms and hands and we
can see that really clearly just by
looking at a bat but also it's even more
clear when we look at the embryos
developing step by step this here we're
back to the the stinger of a honeybee
and so you can probably imagine that I'm
going to make the case that these
thing of a hunt of a honeybee is an
exaptation that's how it evolved but
what from when I was probably a freshman
in high school I I've always liked
playing in the yard even you know today
and catching and catching bugs and I
caught a katydid in the yard and was
just you know trying to look at it and
check out its Anatomy and I saw what I
thought was a giant stinger coming off
its abdomen and so I you know set it
down and backed away and I went to my
biology teacher in school and I asked
the katydids have stingers because I did
not think they had stingers and he said
no they have ovipositor x' and an
ovipositor OVA means egg positive means
you know depositor so it's a neg
depositing device and a lot of insects
have these and what she uses it for
she'll stab it into the ground only the
females have these by the way she'll
stab into the ground and she'll lay her
eggs in the soil and that way they're
safe they can grow there and until
they're ready and then they can emerge
and like I said lots of insects have
ovipositor x' we haven't been able to
work out perfectly the origin of them
through the fossil record because it's
so spotty in the in the origin of the
ovipositor but many insects have them
some are very simple like this
grasshopper
it's ovipositor is basically a scraping
device it just kind of scrapes the
ground and lays its eggs in there as
well and there are very complex
ovipositor x' like the one found on the
cicada the ovipositor of the cicada is
strikingly similar to the stinger of a
bee if we look at it close up we see
that they're very every structure is
essentially the same we've got a
stabilizing rod that first stabs in
there not stabbing into people or
animals they're stabbing into trees and
then we've got these digging blades that
carve open the bark in the case of the
cicada and the digging blades that dig
into your skin in the case of a bee
these function in exactly the same way
and the cicada uses this to carve a hole
in a tree and lay her eggs inside moving
forward we have wasp ovipositor x' and
wasps many species of wasp actually lay
their eggs inside living animals other
living creatures this wasp is injecting
her eggs into a caterpillar and the next
image I'm going to show you a little bit
gruesome but those will hatch out of
that caterpillar and that's how they
start their lives back to bees I had
known for a long time I don't know if I
learned this in school or watching too
many nature documentaries or what it was
but I had learned that worker bees are
females they can sometimes lay eggs
queen bee is a female her job is to lay
eggs and drone bees are males and this
assumption that I developed I with all
these things that I've learned about
ovipositor I've been stunned by this bee
I came up with a theory and the theory
that I had was that bee stingers evolved
from ovipositor x' I turns out I'm not
the first person to come up with this
theory it's actually been written about
extensively for many years but I didn't
know that at the time I figured bee
stingers must be modified ovipositor x'
that's what they are and in science when
we have a theory a theory is an
explanation that explains multiple facts
that have been observed and we can use a
theory to come up with a prediction or a
hypothesis and so the hypothesis or the
prediction that I came up with is that
if this thing of a bee is in fact a
modified ovipositor male bees should not
have stingers that was my prediction and
I did a little live investigation work
and I realized that in fact my
prediction was correct male bees do not
have stingers instead they have a little
bit of fuzz on their rear and what this
told me is that the theory that I come
up with
is supported by the evidence
the Stinger of abhi is in fact a
modified ovipositor so what is the moral
of this story next time you're stung by
a bee you've actually been wounded by
the modified reproductive organs of a
lady insect thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
you